UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
ONE AGAIN WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
IN RESPONSE TO THE COPA
NINETEEN EMERGENCY INTERPRET
PROTECT THE PUBLIC- LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO FORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE THE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS WILL
ALLOW. AND WE'LL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR. TWO EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
FOR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE
IT AND YOU WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN THE CURRENT DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION SPEED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSE TO SAY MENTORS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIFETIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE CHOOSE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE FIVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA BEFORE WE HEAR
THE PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS.
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM DO WE
HAVE A QUORUM NO QUORUM SO WE
WILL BEGIN. AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF THE COMMITTEE TO HEAR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. THE FIRST BILL TO BE
HEARD IS FIGHT WILL GO DIRECTLY
TO ITEM NUMBER- ITEM NUMBER
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR
CURRY. EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT FOUR
THREE A BILL RELATING TO
CALIFORNIA'S PORTFOLIO STANDARD
PROGRAM. BUT RENEWABLES
PORTFOLIO STANDARD PROGRAM. A
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER PRESENT
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME OR WITH MY OFFICE.
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY THREE IS A
NARROW BILL CLAIM TO BUT AIM TO
ALLOW COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS FOR CCA'S. TO
ACCESS AN EXISTING STATE
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES COST
RECOVERY FOR RENEWABLE BIO
ENERGY ELECTRICITY PROJECTS
INCLUDING BIO MONTH MASS AND
BIOGAS. EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE DOES NOT PROPOSE ANY
STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO THE
EXISTING BIO ENERGY PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWS FOR SIMILAR
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROGRAM WITH THE NEW APPLICANTS
AS CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED. ALL
CCAA PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACTS
UNDER BY- OUT PROGRAM WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME OVERSIGHT
AND COST RECOVERY TERMS AS
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES OR
I'LL USE CONTRACTS. THE BILL
ADDRESSES P. C. OVERSIGHT
EXPLICITLY REQUIRING PARALLEL
PROGRAM TERMS AND CONDITIONS
AND ONLY ALLOWS PROCUREMENT OF
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS. URRENTLY
ONLY I'LL USE ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE PILOT PROGRAM AND
THERE IS AVAILABLE CAPACITY
REMAINING UNDER THE TUNER FIFTY
MEGAWATTS CAPS SET. IN STATUTE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT LIFT THE CAP
OR MANDATE ADDITIONAL
PROCUREMENT OF BIOENERGY.
BECAUSE CCA CUSTOMERS ARE
PAYING FOR THESE PROJECTS THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THEIR OWN
PROCUREMENT IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE FOR COMMUNITIES AND THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH STATE
POLICY. ADDITIONALLY IN THE
CPUS MOST RECENT REVIEW OF THE
BOMBING PROGRAM ENERGY DIVISION
STAFF RECOMMENDED THE CCA'S
AMONG OTHERS BE PERMITTED TO
PROCURE AND RECOVER COSTS FOR
THE PILOT PROGRAM. THE BY MAIL
PROGRAM WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE PRIOR TO THE
WIDESPREAD ADOPTION CCA SO THIS
BILL REFLECTS THE CURRENT
PROCUREMENT LANDSCAPE OF THE
STATE. BUT BETTER UTILIZING THE
BIO MAT PROGRAM A. B. EIGHT
FORTY THREE WILL PROVIDE
INCENTIVES. FOR RESPONSIBLE
FOREST AND AGRICULTURAL LAND
MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS PROVIDING
POTENTIAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
RESOURCES FOR MICROGRID. AND
BACKUP ENERGY PROJECTS WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR SAM
KING OF THE OF THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER OF PIONEER
ENERGY. AND TIM FLANAGAN THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF MONTEREY
REGIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. WE WILL
STAY IN TUNE WITH OUR NORMAL
POLICY TO ALLOW ORGANIZED
PRESENTATIONSTHREE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
OPPOSING. WE HAVE TWO SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT SO WE'LL GO SPLIT
THOSE THREE MINUTES BY EACH
SPEAKER MR FLANAGAN YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE WEB SO VOICE
YOU'RE TELLING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JIM FLANAGAN THE
GENERAL MANAGER MONTEREY
REGIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY THREE PART
DISTRICTS MISSION IS TO TURN
WASTE INTO RESOURCES IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE COST EFFECTIVE
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
MANNER. WE ARE ONE OF THE FIRST
IN THE NATION TO DEVELOP
RENEWABLE ENERGY FROM OUR
LANDFILL GAS. NEARLY FOUR
DECADES AGO. DESTRUCTIVE WAVES
THE FORTY LIKE OURSELVES OR
RECORDED OVER 75% OF THE
ORGANIC WASTE. FROM LANDFILLS
LIKE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. RIGHT
NOW THE HIGH COST OF BIOMASS
CONVERSION CAMPERS ARE AT
STORY. FROM PURSUING. NEW
BIOENERGY PROJECTS. YEAH COULD
DIVERT ORGANIC MATERIAL ON THE-
WHILE PROVIDING A BASELINE
POWER TO OUR LOCAL I. T. C. A
NEARLY BECAUSE THE LEGISLATION
BEHIND THE STAGE FILED THAT
RATE. IS NOT EXPRESSLY STATED
HER NAME D. C. AGES ABOUT
MAPREDUCE OVEN DESPITE THE C.
D. USY SAYING THAT ALL THE RATE
PAYERS PAY FOR THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM. FOR LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES AND AGENCIES
LIKE AROUND BY WINNING THREE
BROTHERS PRESENT A PATH FORWARD
TO ADDRESS THE UNENDING DEMANDS
ON THE GOALS OF REDUCING SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTION AND
REDUCING METHANE RENEWABLE
ENERGY PRODUCES. GREAT
STABILITY AND ALSO ALLOWS US
TO. PROTECT THE CURRENT RIGHT
BACK. UP WITH ENERGY WASTE
SOLUTIONS. EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE WOULD ALLOW GREATER TO
GREATER MARKET FOR POWER WE ARE
COMMITTED TO HELPING MAKE OUR
GOALS FOR THE STATE MANDATED
PROGRAMS BUT THEY ARE JUST ONE
COMPONENT OF A COMPLIANCE
PATHWAY. TIME IS OBSCENE IN
OTHER DIVERSIONS DON'T ALWAYS
DO THAT WE STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY THREE TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON. NO
LONGER SEND CAN WITH PRIDE
PIONEER ENERGY MISTER CAN YOU
HAVE A MINUTE AND A HALF. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON SIR WAIT SO
SPECTER DOLLY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAM CAN
YOU NOT THE CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER FIVE YEAR COMMUNITY
ENERGY. PIONEERS THE CTA
SERVING OUR TRUSTY CUSTOMERS
AND PLASTER COUNTY AND NINETY
ELDORADO COUNTY IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR A TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ACCOUNTS OF ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION MEGAWATT
HOURS OF ELECTRICITY TO SAINT
PATRICK COUNTY HAS SEVERAL
BIOMASS PROJECTS IN OPERATION
AND PIONEER IS WORKING WITH
DEVELOPERS. TO ADD MORE
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE. THE
TRAINING. I TO AN EXISTING BY-
PRO AT NO ADDITIONAL COST IS
IMPORTANT TO PIONEER FOR TWO
MAIN REASONS. FIRST BEING AT
THE OOTHILLS OF THE SIERRA.
WILDFIRE MITIGATION TO
SUSTAINABLE FOREST MANAGEMENT
USING BIOMASS PROJECT THAT
CREATES BASEBALL ELECTRICITY
CAPACITY. IN A SEVERELY
CONSTRAINED MARKET IS CRITICAL
NOT ONLY FOR PIONEER. BUT FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALLOW PLASTERED ELDORADO COUNTY
DURING SIX PUBLIC SAFETY PUBLIC
POWER SHUT OFF THE BAT. WITH
AVERAGE DURATIONS RANGING FROM
NINETY TO FORTY THREE HOURS.
SECOND THE DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL
BIOMASS PROJECTS WOULD HELP
STIMULATE THE LOCAL ECONOMY. TO
THE CREATION OF LOCAL JOBS AND
ASSOCIATED BENEFITS. FINAL
POINT I WOULD LIKE TO REITERATE
ABOUT THIS BILL ARE ONE IT DOES
NOT CREATE ANY ADDITIONAL COST
IMPACT. TO THE DOES NOT EXPAND
THE PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS. THREE
ALL REPAIRS ARE BACKED BY A MAP
PROGRAM YET ONLY I WILL USE
HAVE ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM. AND
FORCED TO TAKE THE STATED AT
FORTY THREE BUT PROVIDES TGH
ACCESS TO A PROGRAM THAT THEY
ARE ALREADY PAYING FOR. IT DID
NOT RECEIVE ANY BENEFITS FROM.
TRICARE WEST- BY SURE DOLLY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
TIME. I URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU NEVER GO TO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FORTY THREE- BEGINNING
WITH ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY. THE TIME IT MAY BE
HIDING FROM MY VIEW. NO NOBODY-
HOW ABOUT ROOM ONE TWELVE
ANYBODY THERE. HE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT. EIGHT THREE
EIGHT FOUR THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. RECOMMEND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO AND FIRST WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASPASIA CULTURE
QUICK CALIFORNIA FIGHTERS ON
BEHALF OF BUYING ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS
BIGGER. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE. HI JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE NEXT BIGGER WHITE LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY TWO. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHICH IS
MARKED ENSURE MAKER FOR
POTENTIAL CLEAN ENERGY AND
VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY ONE STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU NECK SPEAKER.
ONE ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE NIGHTMARE
ON BEHALF AND C. E. THIRTEEN
CUSTOMERS IN CONTRA COSTA NAPA
AND SOLANO SOLANO IN MARIN
COUNTY AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE SO
SHE CAN THANK YOU SO MUCH. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED NINETY SIX. HELLO
THIS IS BRIAN CAMPBELL
REPRESENTING CENTRAL COAST
COMMUNITY ENERGY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A REPORT GREAT THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX. HI
DAVID ALLEY HILLIARD WITH
REMAPPING POWER AND LIGHT WHAT
ENERGY AND SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
EIGHT FORTY THREE THANK YOU.
NEXT PICKER. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY ONE. HI THIS IS AUDRA
HARTMAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. MR SURE THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. I WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO
ORGANIZED. A PRESENTATIONS IN
OPPOSITION WELCOME TO THE
GALLERY IF ANYONE IS OFTEN
OPPOSITION HERE. NO ONE HAS
SIGNALS ME WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NOBODY PRESENT WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. A. FORTY
THREE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY EIGHT
FOUR THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THAT ZERO. THE COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. IN MEDICARE WE HAVE
NO COMMENT COMING THROUGH AT
THE TIME. VERY WELCOME TO-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WELCOME TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS OR MOTIONS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION. OKAY YES
WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM I
JUST FORGOT. WILLIAM HUNG
THANKS OKAY- CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PRESIDENT WHAT'S THE
PRESENT DOLLY. DOLLY HERE
BECKER. I'D BETTER HERE FORTIS.
BRADFORD HI ME A PRESENT AFTER
PRESENT DOT. AIKMAN FEELS
BETTER THAN THE EIGHT MEN HERE
GONZALEZ HERE GONZALEZ HERE.
GROWTH HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE MAN-
MEN HERE RUBIO PRESENT WITH
YOUR PRESENCE STERN. CHERRY
HAVE CORN WE HAVE A QUORUM OKAY
NOW WE CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
DOLLY. HOW DID YOU WANT TO MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS ARE
STRUCTURALLY S. ZERO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY WELL EQUIPPED WE
LOVE THOSE CLOSING COMMENTS-
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL HI WESSEL
HI DOLLY. DOLLY HI BECKER HI
BECKER HI FORTUS. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I THOUGHT. AIKMAN HI
AIKMAN HI GONZALEZ HI
CONSEILLERS HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG MCGUIRE. MEN ARE MEN
I WILL BE ABLE. WILL BE OUT BY
STERN. ACER. WELL THE BILLS
THAT WILL CLOSE THE KEEP THE
REAL OPEN. PERHAPS THE MEMBERS-
THAT YOU WANT TO ADD ON. BOB TO
MEMBERS PLEASE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
FORTUS DOT. DOUG HIGH GROWTH
HERTZBERG'S REQUIRING STERN
NINE ACER. WHERE WILL MOVE ON
TO ITEM TO AB SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ. NUMBER
RELATING TO UNIVERSAL SERVICE
IN THE LIFELINE PROGRAM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AND
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDS AND THAT
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THIS
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. AB SEVENTY FOUR
STRAIGHT TOWARD MEASURE THAT
WILL MODERNIZE AND IMPROVE
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA LIFELINE
PROGRAM. ADMINISTERED BY THE
CPUC THE LIFELINE PROGRAM
PROVIDES FREE OR DISCOUNTED
PHONE SERVICE TO ABOUT ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA. AT
TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
FOUND THAT 40% OF ELIGIBLE OUT.
HOUSEHOLDS WERE ENROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM. RECENT FIGURES HAVE
INDICATED THAT MORE
BENEFICIARIES HAVE ENROLLED
TODAY RE CERTIFICATION HOWEVER
SEEMS A REMAINS EXTREMELY LOW.
THE RENEWAL PROCESS HEAVILY
RELIES ON MAILING DOCUMENTS
ENROLLEES AND IN TURN REQUIRING
CUSTOMERS TO FILL OUT AND MAIL
BACK THE DOCUMENTS OR COMPLETE
THE PROCESS ONLINE AS A RESULT
TOO MANY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOW ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THE BENEFIT TO THE TO
THIS ARCANE PROCESS. KIND OF
LA- ONLY 25% OF CALIFORNIA'S
LIFELINE AND WILL RELEASE ARE
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE
THIS PROCESS. FURTHER MORE OF
THOSE CUSTOMERS THAT DID NOT
RENEW NEARLY 60% ARE BACK ON
THE PROGRAM WITH ONE YEAR OR
ANOTHER WORDS THEY WANT TO BE
ON THE PROGRAM BUT THE RENEWAL
PROCESS IS TOO BURDENSOME. AB
SEVENTY FOUR SIMPLY DIRECTS THE
PC TO ADOPT UPDATES RULES
WITHIN THEIR EXISTING IN A DATA
BOTH WITHIN THEIR EXISTING
PROCEEDINGS TO REVAMP THE
OUTDATED RECERTIFICATION
PROCESS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW SUBSCRIBERS TO
ENROLL AND RENEW ONLINE OR ON
THE PHONE. AND WOULD DIRECT THE
CPUC TO ADOPT CHANGES WITH THE
GOAL OF ACHIEVING RENEWAL RATES
THAT MATCH THOSE ACHIEVED BY
THE NATIONAL VERIFIER- THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR LIFELINE
SERVICES WITHOUT HAVING TO
NAVIGATE AN ARCHAIC AND
BURDENSOME PROCESS AND I HAVE
SOME WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
CHRIS OR SANCHEZ WITH WESTERN
CENTER. ON LAW AND POVERTY AND-
I HAVE A WITNESS. AVAILABLE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. VERY WELL-
WE HAVE- JUST TO- CONFIRM WE
HAVE CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ-
SPEAKING. IN IN- SUPPORT WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION SPEAKERS SO
IF- MISTER SANCHEZ AND ON THE
LINE YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
ARE YOU HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE
NUMBERS THIS RESPONSE OF
BOBCATS GOOD QUESTIONS ON OUR
PROPERTY INSURANCE THE PART OF
MAYBE EIGHTY SEVENTY FOUR THE
COVER NINETEEN PRACTICE
PROBLEMS ANYTHING CAN ACTIVITY
IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE YOU
KNOW ACCESSING THE PHONE
INTERNET IS ESSENTIAL NOW MORE
THAN EVER. LIFELINE PROGRAM IS
ONLY PROGRAM WHERE YOU HAVE TO
PROVIDE MORE INTO CALIFORNIA
THE COMMUNICATION SERVICES ARE
AFFORDABLE. DURING THE PANDEMIC
QUESTIONS IN OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS FOR NUMEROUS STORIES
OF CALIFORNIANS WERE ONLY ABLE
TO CONNECT TO CRITICAL SOCIAL
SERVICE COMPLEXION CALFRESH CAL
WORKS CAPPY AND MANY OTHERS.
THE FARMERS BECAUSE OFFICES
THAT. WOULD TYPICALLY TAKE YOUR%
PERSONAL COMMENTS ARE CLOSED
WELCOME BACK TO THE INTERNET ON
THE COMPUTER AT THE HOUSEHOLDS
OR SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY PREFER
THE SMOKING DO YOU DID YOUR
PART. THESE ARE SOME EXAMPLES
AND THERE ARE MANY OTHERS THAT
PROVES CONNECTIVITY'S FOOTBALL
MINDEDNESS FINANCIAL OFFER MANY
CALIFORNIANS SPECIALLY FOR
MORNING CALIFORNIA USED TO MY
FRIEND PROGRAM DESPITE
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH MOMENT OUR
NUMBERS FOR THIS PROGRAM- BUT
NO MEANS- THE MOMENT HAS BEEN A
BIT OF A SMALL R. AND BECAUSE
BOTH ARE CONFUSING PROCESS. BUT
THEY HAVE TO READ ALONG. FOR
MANY LONG. WILL APART BENEFITS
WILL PUT OUR SECURE FOR SERVICE.
OUT OF REACH. ABC SEVENTY FOUR
ONE LEVEL TO HELP TO CHECK
RECEIVING BENEFIT THE PROGRAM
BY MODERN. AND STREAMLINING.
HISTORY ALONG WITH PROFIT OF
THE REASONS RESPECT ACTUALLY I.
VERY WELL WE'LL GO SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT. ABC FOUR AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ANY SPEAKERS HERE IN
THE GALLERY. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE- INDICATING AN INTEREST
IN SPEAKING WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE NOBODY IS PRESENT ROOM
TWELVE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR PLEASE CUES
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
SEVENTY FOUR. FOUR COMMENT IN
ORDER. TO EIGHTY SEVEN FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. NO
FIRST WE GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE BETTER LUCK WITH
THE LATEST ON THE APPLICATION.
FOR. A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO. WELL WE GET A LOT
WITH THE BALL PARK OF EIGHTY
SEVENTY FOUR. HE. THE FLYING AT
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE. DANIEL
GOOD HERE THEY'LL BE HAPPY TURN
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WITH
THE SUPPORT OF FERMENTED
POSITION LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR. END OF MEDICARE WE HAVE
ONE MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH YOUR LIFE. IN
A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
YEAR MIKE ECHO. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER POP THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR THANK
YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL. SO WE'LL GO TO THE
GALLERY OF ART THERE ARE ANY
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF AB AB
SEVENTY FOUR I DO NOT SEE ANY
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE NO
ONE IS PRESENT WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY FOUR.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND I
SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THE TIME OKAY WE'LL GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SERVICE CENTER BECKER. THANKS
TO ONE OF COMMAND THE AUTHOR
JUST MAKING GOVERNMENT EASIER
ACCESS IS A PRIORITY OF MINE
AND MAKING BENEFITS EASIER
ACCESS SHOULD BE A PRIORITY FOR
ALL OF US SO HELLO HE
SIGNATURES ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
DO THIS BY THE TELEPHONE IS
COMMON SENSE AND LOOK FOR THE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE MOVE IT
WHEN. APPROPRIATE SENATOR
RECOMMEND. THANK YOU I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR BRINGS
FORWARD IN JUST ONE QUESTION
ABOUT IS IT GOING TO BE AN
EITHER OR FOR MAIL AND OR
ELECTRONICS OF PEOPLE STILL
MAINTAIN THAT BECAUSE OF OUR
OLDER POPULATION SOME OF THEM
ACTUALLY ONE OF Y MAIL WE ALSO
WOULD PROVIDE TELEPHONE AND
OPTION FOR TOP ANSWER
ABSOLUTELY OKAY OKAY. YET WE
TRY TO GET THOSE PEOPLE THAT
OFTENTIMES THE TO THE CRACKS
LIKE WE WANNA PATCH WHATEVER
HOLD THERE MIGHT BE OUT THERE
THAT THEY COULD SLIP TO.
ABSOLUTELY THANK. SO DO WE HAVE
ANY MOTIONS ON THIS BILL. YEAH
WE HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SOME REMEMBER THEMSELVES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NIGHT OUT OKAY VERY
WELL WE HAVE A MOTION- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE- ROLL.
AB SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
HE PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL. BY WESSEL HI DALI. DALI
HI BECKER HI. BECKER I FORGES.
BRADFORD OR BRADFORD HI DOT HI
DAD HI AIKMAN HI AIKMAN HI
CONSOLIDATES HI GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG REQUIRE MAN
HI MAN HI RUBIO HI RUBIO I
STERN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
WE HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO GET THE
LOT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NAZARIAN A BILL RELATED TO
ELECTRIC UTILITIES RATE
REDUCTION BONDS SYMBOL MEMBER
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND SENATORS- GOOD
AFTERNOON. THIS IS- I'D LIKE TO
START OFF- BY ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TO
REQUIRE THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
TO SUBMIT THE ANNUAL REPORT OF
THE C. P. CFA TO THE RELEVANT
POLICY COMMITTEES THAT OVERSEE
ACTIVITY OF THE ELECTRICAL Q.
USE. INCLUDING THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THAT- THIS IS MY
THIRD BILL IN THIS SPACE- TO
MAKE A LESS EXPENSIVE FORM OF
PROJECT FINANCING AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL PUBLIC UTILITIES PURPOSE
HERE IS TO ALLOW LOCAL PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND
THEIR CUSTOMERS TO SAVE MONEY
WHEN FINANCING UTILITY
PROJECTS. MAINTAINING
AFFORDABLE ELECTRIC RATES IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY WILL PROVIDE A USEFUL
TOOL TO HELP KEEP BORROWING
COSTS LOW AND KEEP ELECTRIC
RATES AFFORDABLE RATE REDUCTION
BONDS TYPICALLY OFFER LOWER
INTEREST RATES THAN TRADITIONAL
REVENUE BONDS AND ARE THERE FOR
A FINANCING TOOL THAT YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO UTILIZE TO
SIT ON PROJECT AND PROGRAM.
COSTS THIS CHEAPER FINANCING
TOOL IS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL PUBLIC WATER AND
WASTEWATER UTILITIES AND TO I-
USE BUT IT IS NOT AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE USE AND THEIR CUSTOMERS.
THERE IS- NO PUBLIC POLICY
RATIONALE FOR THIS IMBALANCE IN
THE LAW AND IN CLOSING EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WILL REDUCE
BORROWING COSTS FOR P. O. W.
PEOPLE USE AND THEIR CUSTOMERS
WHEN MAKING INVESTMENTS TO MEET
HE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS
MEDICAID QUALIFIERS. ENHANCE
SAFETY AS WELL AS ADDRESS THAT
THAT HAS ACCUMULATED DUE TO
SOME CUSTOMERS INABILITY TO PAY
THEIR ELECTRIC BILLS DURING THE
CONTINUED COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY. WITH ME I HAVE
PATRICK WELCH WITH C. M. U. A.
AS WELL AS HELP YOU PAUL HEUSER
GENERAL MANAGER OF TRINITY.
PUBLIC UTILITIES DISTRICT. OKAY
SO AS A USUAL POLICY IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SET ASIDE
THREE MINUTES FOR ORGANIZED
PRESENTATIONS. WE HAVE PATRICK
WELCH WELCH AND PAUL HAUSER
WILL BEGIN WITH PATRICK WELCH
YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND A HALF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AFTER
BOX WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HAS FORTY SIX PUBLIC
RENOWN NOT PROFIT ELECT BILL
EITHER BY THE STATE RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE ELECTRICITY TO
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE. ST EIGHTY
SEVEN BY THEY OPERATED AND USED
A FINANCING TOOL THAT CAN HELP
ME TINA PORTABLE ELECTRIC RATES
WHICH ARE RISING AT TWICE AS
FAST. IN CALIFORNIA COMPARED TO
THE REST. THE RATE REDUCTION
BOND UNDER EIGHTY SEVEN
VIOLATORS. FOR LAYERS CULVER
SITE. LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL STATE REVIEW BY THE
CALIFORNIA BASED. FINANCING
AUTHORITY IN A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE SUN ROOF
YOU. FURTHER RATE REDUCTION
BOND CAN ONLY BE ISSUED IF THEY
HAVE LOWER RATES OF TRADITIONAL.
ACCORDING TO THE LECTURE C. AS
IN THE CENTRAL SERVICES EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT PROVIDES AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO THE STATE'S
PUBLIC ON ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
MAKE NEEDED REQUIRED
INVESTMENTS. AT CHEAPER COSTS
TO THEIR CUSTOMERS. AND CREATE
YOUR SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE
TODAY AND THINK DOCTORS WITH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WILL GO TO MR HOUSER YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR WITH- BIKER
DOLLY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS PAUL
WHO'S BEEN ON THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR TRAINEE PUBLIC
UTILITY DISTRICT. ON BEHALF OF
TWENTY P. U. D. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT FOR A. B. SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT. THREE PT PROVIDES A 100%
CARBON FREE ELECTRICITY TO
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN RURAL
TRINITY COUNTY. OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY COVERS TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES OF THE
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST FIRE
PRONE. THE POPULATION WE SERVE
IS ALSO AMONG THE POOREST IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT OF
CALIFORNIA'S STRICT LIABILITY
STANDARD AS IT RELATES TO
UTILITY WHILE PARTLY LIABILITY
COMMITTEE PD IS NO LONGER ABLE
TO PROCURE WALL CAR LIABILITY
INSURANCE. NOT ONLY DID THIS
EXPOSICIONES DE CONSIDERABLE
BANKRUPTCY REAL. BUT IT ALSO
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT
DOWNGRADES YOUR CREDIT RATING.
WE LEFT REFINANCE DEBT ON
NOVEMBER FIRST OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MORE CREDIT RATING
WAS DOUBLE A MINUS. THE DAY OUR
RATING IS TRIPLE BE PLUS. THIS
IS INCREASED OUR CALLS
REQUIRING CAPITAL JUST WHEN WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS TO
EXPAND OUR RIGHT OF WAY EMPIRE
PARTNER SYSTEM. EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT HOLD THE POTENTIAL
TO REDUCE OUR BORROWING COSTS
OF THE- WHAT THEY WERE PRIOR TO
OUR CREDIT RATING DOWNGRADE. SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS TO REDUCE FIRE
RISK AND MAKE ELECTRIC SERVICE
MORE RELIABLE. BUT TRINITY
COUNTY BEING ONE OF THE POOREST
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
DIFFICULT TO MAKE LARGE CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES WITHOUT FINANCING
THE EXPENSES AND SPREADING THAT
COST OVER TIME. I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT OF THE
TWENTY P. UT AND OTHER PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES CAN ACCESS
LOWER COST FINANCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE REST. OKAY WE'LL
GO TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
BEGINNING WITH ANYONE HERE IN
THE GALLERY ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WITH. NO ONE HERE- HOW
ABOUT ONE TWELVE ANYBODY ONE
TWELVE NOON THERE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR FOR COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE TEN ZERO. LINE A ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY
KIDS UP. HELLO ANASTASIA
COUPLED TOGETHER WITH
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ON BEHALF OF
THIS MONTH IN SUPPORTED AB
SEVEN FIFTY THANK YOU. NEXT ONE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN. MR KAREN
MEMBER TOLD ME AT THE LEAD SHOT
THAT HAPPENED THIRTY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THE OFFICE
OF MAYOR LONDON BREED IN COURT
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR. ONE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR HERE MIKE AT THE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON HEATHER
DOLLAR WITH CITY OF PALO ALTO
UTILITIES DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT.
LINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THERE DOLPHY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE. TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU
YOUR NUMBERS YOU CANNOT GO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY THE CHAIR MEMBERS CRAIG
COOK GROUP IS A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
MEDICARE THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME. OKAY VERY
WELL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT THERE'S NO ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION IN OPPOSITION TO
HAVE ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT. NO ONE IS INDICATING.
HOW ABOUT ONE TWELVE ANYBODY
ONE TWELVE NO ONE IS PRESENT
ROOM ONE TWELVE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE KILL ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE ZERO. WE HAVE ONE COMMENT
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THEIR LIFE NUMBER. ONE
MORE MOMENT PLEASE. THE FLIGHT
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE YOU'RE
MY KIND OF. OKAY MY NAME IS
STORM OUT IN TIME A
REPRESENTATION FOR WHATEVER
COUNSEL AND WE ALREADY SUPPORT.
OKAY WILL BE REGISTERED AS A
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT OF SB OF ABC
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. AND MISTER KERR WE
HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH. ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
YEAR MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CARE OFF OF THE OF THE CITY OF
BURBANK. PART OF THE
METROPOLITAN FOR CALLING A BOMB
ALAN. SO THAT IS ANOTHER SPORT
OKAY VERY WELL- MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. SEVEN FIVE
EIGHT. BETTER CARE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
OKAY WE'LL COME TO THE FLOOR
NOW AND ANYTHING FROM MEMBERS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOTIONS.
THAT WOULD BE A MOTION TO- OF
THE BILL TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. A SIMILAR
NUMBER DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS. I HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IPHONE
THANK YOU VERY WELL- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A. B. SEVEN FIVE EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL BY
WHISTLE HI DOLLY HI SALLY HI
BECKER HI BECKER HI FORTUS.
BRADFORD BRADFORD FIVE DOT FIVE
DOT HI AIKMAN HI AIKMAN I
GONZALEZ. CLOSE ALL THIS HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG MCGUIRE MAN
HI MAN HI RUBIO HI RUBIO I
STERN. NINE EASTER OKAY THE.
THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OF THE
PROPS OF MEMBERS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SENATORS.
BOOKABLE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
A. B. OURTEEN TWENTY FIVE
QUESTION REMEMBER GIBSON A BILL
RELATED. TO THE BROADBAND
HOUSING ACCOUNT. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS FIRST OF ALL LET ME
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE WANT TO
THANK THE GERMANS- TEAM WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY TEAM TO
STRAIGHTEN HIS BILL TO MAKE
THIS BILL BETTER. THANK YOU FOR
AGAIN ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE WHICH WOULD. TRANSFER
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO THE BROADBAND
PUBLIC HOUSING ACCOUNT UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICE
FUND. UPON ONE APPROPRIATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE. TO IF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION DETERMINES. THERE IS
SUFFICIENT FUNDS. THESE TWO
PROVISIONS OFFERS MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY NOW WOULD
UNDERSCORE MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY
TO THE PC TO MAKE CONNECTING
ALL PUBLIC HOUSING RESIDENTS
THEIR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY AP
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE ALSO SET A
GOAL TO CONNECT TO CONNECT ALL
RESIDENTS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
OR SOON. THESE FUNDS WILL
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDE GRANTS TO
CONNECT RESIDENTS LIVING IN
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
BROADBAND. INTERNET ACCESS IS A
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUE SENATORS
MY STAFF SAID EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU AN EXCEL SPREADSHEET ON
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
THAT'S IN YOUR DISTRICT. I WANT
TO UNDERSCORE THAT WE KNOW THAT
40% OF ALL PEOPLE LIVING IN
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
COMPLEXES REMAIN UNCONNECTED TO
THE INTERNET. THIS PAST WEEKEND
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WALK
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT.
DURING DURING TIS PANDEMIC-
40% OF FAMILIES IN NICKERSON
GARDENS WHILE WALKED THIS PAST
WEEKEND I THOUGHT I WAS WALKING
PRECINCTS BUT I WAS WALKING
DOOR TO DOOR PASSING OUT FLYERS
TALKING ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY TWENTY FIVE NO ONLY
NICKERSON GARDENS JORDAN DOWNS.
NOT ONLY JORDAN DOWNS AND
IMPERIAL COURTS AND ALSO
CONTACT VILLAGE IN WHAT'S
WHAT'S WHERE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED. INDIVIDUALS TALKED
ABOUT HOW THEY HAD NO
CONNECTION TO THE INTERNET DO
YOU UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS WE TALK ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC
AND STUDENTS TRYING TO. GET
CONNECTED TO INTERNET WE'RE
DISTANCING LEARNING AND THEY
HAVE NO INTERNET ACCESS NO
SERVICE. THEY CANNOT DO THAT.
WITH THE WITH THIS DELTA
VARIANTS. ON THE RISE WE CAN
NOT HAVE TO CALIFORNIA'S LET ME
REPEAT THAT WE CANNOT HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA WE CANNOT HAVE A
CALIFORNIA THAT'S CONNECTED AND
ONE THAT IS NOT CONNECTED.
MEMBERS WE NEED TO CONNECT
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA TO THE
INTERNET WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS
MISTAKENLY HERNANDEZ FROM THE
SOUTHEAST COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION TO SPEAK. ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND MISTER
STEVE POND TALE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THIS
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I BUILT
THE PROTOTYPE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SOME REMEMBER GIBSON I
JUST WANT IT FOR THE RECORD TO
GET YOU TO CONFIRM THAT YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE MEDICAMENT HAVE
SOLUTION. OKAY THEN WE'LL GO TO
EMMA HERNANDEZ FOLLOWED BY
STEEP ON TELL- WE WILL STICK TO
OUR POLICY OF THREE MINUTES PER
ORGANIZE PRESENTATION. SO MISS
AMBER HERNANDEZ YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF. HELLO EMMA
HERNANDEZ I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT SOUTHEAST COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION WE'RE
REGIONAL COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT NONPROFIT. SERVING
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
THE PIECE DELAY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FORTY TWENTY
FIVE BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO THE
INTERNET IS NOT A LUXURY. IT IS
A NECESSITY MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES WERE IMPACTED. BY
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE LACK
OF ACCESS TO INTERNET THE
COMPUTER TO DO BASIC DIGITAL
LITERACY. 89% OF OUR CALLS ARE
NOT FULLY CONNECTED. NEIGHBOR
KIDS WERE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
CLASSROOMS ONLINE AND- GOT
BORED BROADBAND. WHAT IS
REVEALED WE ARE. IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FORTY TWENTY NINE. THE
FIVE OR TO CONNECT PUBLIC THAT
I'VE TO YOU. PROVIDE DIGITALLY
PRETTY FOR RESIDENTS AND ASSIST
THEM IN GETTING APPROPRIATE
COMPUTING IF I COULD. NOT HAVE
NOT CONTINUE TO HINDER OUR KIDS
AND OUR FAMILY. WITH THE LACK
OF PROGRESS. SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE EVEN
THOSE RESIDING IN SUBSIDIZED
HOW THE OUR RESIDENTS ARE
COMPLETELY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
ARE BY DEFINITION. REPORTER
CALIFORNIANS. ARE MOST.
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. NOW GO ON TO MARK
GRAHAM NO I'M SORRY TO STEVE
PUN TELL YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND
A HALF. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEVE
CONTEL PRESIDENCY OUT NATIONAL
COMMUNITY RENAISSANCE WITH THE
FIFTH LARGEST NONPROFIT OWNER
DEVELOPER OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE COUNTRY. WITH NEARLY
NINE THOUSAND UNITS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE'RE
HEADQUARTERED INCLUDING
NINETEEN COMMUNITIES SAN DIEGO
ANNUALLY TWO THOUSAND UNITS ON
BEHALF OF THE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE
IN. SUBSIDIZED HOUSING. I AM
PLEASED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. I'M
AS WHERE THE CODE NINETEEN IS
BUT A SPOTLIGHT ON THE NEED.
FOR GREATER ACCESS TO BROADBAND
AND THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IS A
REAL THING. GOVERNMENT HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS SHOULD NOT HAVE A SOURCE
OF FUNDING TO INSTALL INTERNET
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I'D LIKE TO
SEE PROJECTS. OR TRAIN OUR
RESIDENTS TO BECOME DIGITALLY
LITERATE. OPERATING BUDGETS FAR%
OLDER PROPERTIES ARE SET YEARS
AGO AND WE DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO PAY FOR THE
INTERNET ACCESS WE NEED. I AM
HONORED TO EFFICIENTLY GIVES
AND FOR HIM FOR HIS WORK SIR DO
YOU UNDERSTAND IN OUR STATE.
THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO GET
EVERYONE CONNECTED JUST
PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING AND
STICK A MODEST STEP FOR
DEDICATING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
A YEAR. IN FUNDING AS
AUTHORIZED BY LEGISLATION TO
THE PC. HOW DOES WITH GREAT
PLEASURE THAT I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT AT FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU- MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ROOM BUT NUMBERS AT.
TWENTY FORTY C. NINE WELL YOU
WILL GO TO. OPPOSITION WE HAVE-
MARK NO- FOR LUNCH SORRY WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO LINE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON PICK ME
STAND ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE A. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE. BARTON DR JOHN BEHALF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA THANKS REPRESENTING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORTED AT
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
ONE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. HI MY
NAME IS WANDA CLEVELAND WHAT
CLEAN ENERGY. ERIN ENERGY TO
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ALL OF
THE ACTORS STRUCTURE IS PUT
THERE WELL THE WHOLE COMMUNITY
WILL BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
THIS ECAUSE WE'VE BEEN MADE
PROMISES BEFORE ONE FIBER OPTIC
WAS PUT ON THE ALAMEDA CORRIDOR
SHOW. WHICH IS WHAT MAKES TO
MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT ARE
THRUST AGAINST COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. LINE AT. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY. HI GOOD DAY CAN YOU HEAR
ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU- MY NAME IS
TOM I'M ALREADY IN A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I'M IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE
ENSURE THEY'RE ALL LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN PUBLIC HOUSING
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET DID YOU TAKE YOUR
DISTANCE LEARNING THANK YOU.
HELLO JUST NAME. ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. LINE TWO HUNDRED YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. DON'T GO THE
BETTER WHAT YOU SEE THERE I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY. GOOD EVENING
JENNIFER POCKET THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE.
HELLO MY NAME IS TIM ACROSS
CAIRNS CEO OF ALL TO SEE AT THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
WE COMMEND THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO. LIVE ABOUT THE OLD FIGURE
AT ALL- SUPPORTED SERVER THE
COORDINATOR AND JOINT ON THAT
VEHICLE AND I AM STRONG WITH
THE BALL NOW WITHOUT THE
WALKING OUT OF THE WOODS- AT W.
NUMBER MIGHT GET IN THE OFFICE.
FOR FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. FOUR
NINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE.
THIS IS DON WILLIAMS SUPPORTING
AV. FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN. CLAUDIA
CARDINALE WITH PRINTERS ABOUT
MEN IN SUPPORT. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT. FORMER
STATE SENATOR RICHARD POLANCO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MERGING TECHNOLOGY FUND
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF THE ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THAT NEED TO BE CONNECTED IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ONE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE. VANISH
AROUND BILL PLUS COMMUNITY
MARKETPLACE WATCH CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIEL HOGAN I
AM WHAT'S THE BETTER OPTION
ISSUE THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION BASED OUT OF WHAT
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AT.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED FOUR. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY YES
JACQUELYN BY DAYS SO BY
CONTACTING EGO TO SIXTY LA-
ECOLOGICAL COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
FOR THE COMMUNITY WE ARE IN. OF
THE BILL THANK YOU ARE.
SPECIALLY FOR THE ART DURING
ALL IN SUPPORT. NINE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WILL BE AT THE LEAST
SHOCK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AN ONLINE TWO HUNDRED TWELVE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED TWELVE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MECHANICALLY URBAN
SUPPORT OF. EIGHT AND WE LOST
TO TWELVE MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO-
MARKRAM AND RUN AT CERTAIN. YOU
HAVE TO ADMIT A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES APIECE. SO GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING SHARE
PRICE OWN SENATORS MARK GRAHAM
ON BEHALF OF KEEP CELL ANTENNAS
AWAY. THIS BILL IS NOT REALLY
HI SPEED INTERNET PLEASE READ
SECTION TWO EIGHT ONE B. AS IN
BABY OF THIS BILL WHILE THE
GOAL OF PROVIDING HIGH SPEED
INTERNET ACCESS TO CALIFORNIANS
LIVING IN PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED
MULTI UNIT HOUSING COMPLEXES IS
A LAUDABLE THIS STILL FALLS FAR
SHORT BY ALLOWING ALLOWING
PROVIDERS TO USE CHEAP CELL
ANTENNAS. WHICH WILL BOTH CAUSE
HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS AND WILL
FAIL TO DELIVER REAL HIGH SPEED
INTERNET SERVICE. THERE IS A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE CHOICE
OF TECHNOLOGY HEALTH EFFECTS
AND SPEED THIS BILL SHOULD BE
VOTED DOWN OR AMENDED TODAY TO
REQUIRE THE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE FIBRE OPTIC CABLES INTO
EACH APARTMENT. WHICH WILL
SOLVE BOTH PROBLEMS INTERNET
SPEED HAS COME A LONG WAY SINCE
THE NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN ONE
TO SIX MEGABITS PER SECOND OF
DATA WAS CONSIDERED GOOD
INTERNET SPEED TODAY THAT IS
VERY SLOW TODAY THIRTY TO ONE
HUNDRED MEGABITS PER SECOND IS
CONSIDERED HIGH SPEED. IN JUNE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE THE US
TREASURY DEPARTMENT PUBLISHED
ITS FUNDING REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE CORONAVIRUS STATE AND LOCAL
PHYSICAL RECOVERY FUNDS. AND
BASICALLY WHAT THEY SAY IS THE
REQUIREMENT FOR ANY ELIGIBLE
PROJECT PROJECT IS IT HAS TO
PROVIDE UPLOAD AND DOWNLOAD
SPEED OF ONE HUNDRED MEGABITS
PER SECOND. IF YOU PASS THIS
BILL AND IT BECOMES LAW.
PROVIDERS WILL MAKE MILLIONS BY
USING CHEAP CELL ANTENNAS
RESIDENTS WILL SUFFER FROM
HEALTH EFFECTS IN INSOMNIA AND
YOU WILL HEAR MANY COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE SLOW INTERNET SPEED.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO DO IT. I
URGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FINE PRINT AMEND THIS BILL OR
VOTE IT DOWN TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU YOUR WAY SO AND UNDER
I'M FORMER TWO TIME MAYOR AND
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER OF NEVADA
CITY I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
WHAT WE CLEARLY KNOW REGARDING
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
WIRELESS IS CHEAP THIRD RATE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE FAR
INFERIOR TO FIBER OPTIC OR
CABLE SERVICE DIRECTLY TO
HOMES. INTO THE STRUCTURE'S NOT
RELIABLY FAST NOR SYMMETRIC
BROADBAND MUST HAVE THE SAME
SPEED DOWN AND UP PER THE
DEPARTMENT TREASURIES JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FUNDING%
REQUIREMENTS FOR BROADBAND
COVERED BY RICH RECOVERY PLANS
WHY WAS BOB AND CAN'T MEET THE
STANDARD WILL GLASS BE CHECKED
AND PC MAGAZINE VERIFIED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIVE G. IS NO
FASTER THAN FOUR G. IT'S AN
ASYMMETRIC UPLOAD SPEEDS ARE
SMALL FRACTION OF THE DOWNLOAD
SPEEDS ONE HUNDRED MEGABITS UP
AND DOWN ARE REQUIRED FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING. ONLY CABLE OR
FIBER TO THE HOME CAN DO THIS
UNLIKE WIRELESS WHICH IS NOT
FUTURE PROOF IT WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR WIRELESS TO KEEP
UP TO THE BANDWIDTH DEMAND
FIBER OPTIC CAN CARRY A MILLION
TIMES. MORE DATA THAN WIRELESS
CAN. TREASURY WORK. QUALIFYING
PROJECT MUST DELIVER THE
METRICS THEY COULD BE SERVICE
AND SENDING. THE BILL SHOULD
PROVIDE SOLID SERVICE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PRESERVE THE QUIET
ENJOYMENT OF ST RATHER THAN
PUTTING NEIGHBORHOODS BUT CELL
TOWERS. DON'T SHORT CHANGE
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERPRIVILEGED
COMMUNITIES. A LOT OF COMPANIES
TO COLLECT MONEY AND DELIVER
CLEARLY INADEQUATE SERVICE.
SUPPORT SYMMETRIC SERVICE THANK
YOU YOUR WAY SOUTH AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON THE BILL AND PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND TO BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. FIBER. THANK YOU YOUR
TIME IS UP THANK YOU- NOW
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY. C.
NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE C. NINE
WILL GO TO THE LINES
PROPOSITION MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE THEM UP. NAME THE
AFFILIATION IN OPPOSITION. OR.
SEVENTY ONE TWELVE FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THE
COMMAND AGAIN ONE WITH AN ZERO.
AND MISTER CHAIR I SHOW NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK NOW TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE
I BELIEVE SO. MIKE IS A PURE GO
AHEAD SIR- PARTS PART YES
SEARCH FOR GOD'S SAKE YOU HEAR
MY NAME THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN.
YOU KNOW I HAVE. BEEN AROUND
THIS INSTITUTIONAL LONG TIME. I
HAVE YET TO SEE TIM MCCOSKER
FROM ALL TO SEE EVERS COME
BEFORE THIS LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT ANYTHING IN. EVEN
THOUGH HE WAS THE CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR THE APPOINTED IRAN
AGAINST FOR MAYOR OF LOS
ANGELES AND HE BEAT ME PRETTY
GOOD. I HOLD THEM IN THE
HIGHEST REGARD. YEAH AND I
THINK THAT IS C. N. CENTER
PALUMBO WHO WAS A INSTITUTION
THIS PLACE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR
ME I STAND WITH THE AUTHOR WILL
VOTE FOR THIS MISSION. THE
SEARCH ERGO CENTER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND I TOO
WANT TO THINK THAT THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AS WE'RE WORKING ON
A MEGA BILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE
FOR BROADBAND AND YOU'RE
THINKING OF THOSE WHO ARE IN
OUR PUBLIC HOUSING BEING ABLE
TO EXPLICITLY AND SURE THAT
THERE IS ROOM FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE WE CAN
GIVE- YOU KNOW KIDS AND PEOPLE
LIVING IN PUBLIC HOUSING ALL OF
THE WIFI HOT SPOTS AND THAT THE
COMPUTERS IN THE DIGITAL
LITERACY BUT IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. WHICH HAS
BEEN DELINEATED BY THE COMEDIAN
AND ALICE'S IN WHICH YOU'VE-
ACCEPTED I THINK IS GREAT AND
IT ONLY COMPLEMENTS THE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS WE'RE GOING
TO BE GETTING- HERE SHORTLY
THAT HAS BEEN WORKED ON BY BOTH
HOUSES SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
FORWARD WE NEED TO JUST KEEP
PUSHING ON FOR MORE- OF THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK THE
AUTHOR AS WELL I'VE SPENT TEN
YEARS ON THE BOARD OF A
NONPROFIT- WANNA CONDAMINE WE
HAD TO BRING IT HOME. CAMPAIGN
TO- WAR BASICALLY REQUIRE
FORMAL BROADBAND ACCESS IN NEW.
A FORMER HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
AND THEN HAD TO SHOW. A
TRAINER'S PROGRAM WE WOULD
TRAIN YOUNG PEOPLE TOO THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT PAY THEM TO GO
TRAIN EVERYONE ELSE IN THERE.
AND ACTUALLY HAD A BRONCO BHAMA
AND JOHN MCCAIN AS PART OF THAT
BRING IT HOME CAMPAIGN. WHICH
IS GREAT BECAUSE IT SHOWS YOU
HOW HOW DIFFICULT THIS THIS IS
THE FACT WE'RE STILL STRUGGLING
WITH THIS. PROBLEM WE ALSO HAVE
CENTER BRADFORD'S BILL ON THE
SAME. TOPIC MIGHT MY QUESTION
FOR YOU IS YOU WHO IS THE MAIN
PROBLEM THAT PEOPLE. DON'T HAVE
THE OPTION OF BROADBAND
SERVICE. BECAUSE THERE'S NO
PROVIDER IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD.
OR IS IT MORE CALM THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE BROADBAND BECAUSE
IT'S EITHER TOO EXPENSIVE. THEY
DON'T HAVE A COMPUTER OR THEY
NEED DIGITAL LITERACY TRAINING.
IN ORDER TO KNOW HOW TO USE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FORTY
PERCENT. OF THE- INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE NO ACCESS- IT'S
AND IT'S NOT SO MUCH
AFFORDABILITY BECAUSE- THOSE
WHO DO HAVE IT. IT'S POORLY
CONNECTED- AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THOSE WHO LIVE. IN MY DISTRICT.
AND YOU LOOK AT A TIME IN WHICH
THOSE PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
WERE BUILT. THEIR BILL WHICH
CENTER BOX SO THE INTERNET. THE
SERVICES OR THE CONNECTIVE ITTY
CAN EVEN PENETRATE- GETTING THE
SIGNAL INTO THE HOME- THEY HAVE
BUFFERING DAD'S GOES ON. KIDS
INTERNET STARTS AND THEN IT
JUST CONTINUES. AND SO IT'S A
VARIETY OF ISSUES- AND THAT'S
JUST ONLY IN MY DISTRICT BUT
YOU LOOK AT. YOU KNOW ALL OF
CALIFORNIA THERE'S PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NO ACCESS WHATSOEVER- WE
TALK ABOUT CHILDREN TRYING TO
DISTANCE LEARNING- THEY CAN'T
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO ACCESS TO.
THE INTERNET THE BROADBAND-
SERVICE AND THIS BILL IS TRYING
TO ERADICATE THAT BY MAKING
SURE. THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE
ACCESS TO SUCH TECHNOLOGY CAN
YOU I MEAN WE HAVE STORIES IN
WHICH IN MY DISTRICT. THE KIDS
KIDS IN THE FAMILY HAVE NO
INTERNET ACCESS- BACK AND GO TO
THEIR PARTICULAR HOME SO THEY
HAVE TO ACTUALLY GO IN THE
GARAGE. AND GET CONNECTED TO
SOMEONE ELSE'S CONNECTION AND
THAT THOSE ARE STORIES THAT ARE
REPEATED TIME AND TIME AGAIN
AND SO THIS BILL IS SEEKING A
TO ADDRESS. IS THE SYSTEMIC
PROBLEM X. SPECIALLY IN THE
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING JUST
WITH SENATOR. IN SOUTH WAS
SAYING- WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE. PUT IN PLACE
THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE. THE KIND
OF SERVICES THAT IS NEEDED. F.
AND I PER THAT IN AN- YOU KNOW
THAT'S HOW I GUESS QUITE IS.
THIS POST I GUESS SEEMS TO
FOCUS ON NEW INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
PROVIDE FREE SERVICE RATHER
THAN TRYING TO SUBSIDIZE
SERVICE MAKES TEAM. BROADBAND
PROVIDERS AND- I GUESS THAT'S
WAS WONDERING YOU KNOW IS THAT
THE ISSUE OF THEIRS. SERVICE
FOR THE COULD BE SERVICE IS
JUST TOO EXPENSIVE OR DO WE
REALLY NEED TO. BE GIVING
GRANTS TO. BUILD ALL NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE. SURE I THINK WE
HAVE MISSED BUT MUCH OF THE
TAIL ON THE LINE WHO CAN
ADDRESS THAT MORE TECHNICAL.
MORE TECHNICALLY FOR ME. GO TO
THE FALL LINE WITH MISTER PATEL.
HE'S HE'S GONE HE'S HUNG UP
OKAY. SO SENATOR THERE ARE
WHICH WHICH SPEAKER WHERE YOU-
REQUESTING- IT WAS EITHER-
EMILY HERNANDEZ OR PATEL. OR OR
STEVE PUN TELLER EMMA HERNANDEZ
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE. THERE
ARE NO LONGER ON THE LINE OKAY.
YEAH YES I AM ON THE LINE OKAY.
OF M. HERNANDEZ ON THE LINE.
COULD YOU PUT YOUR QUESTION
AGAIN. MISTER GIBSON FOUR
THIRTY. THE SENATOR COULD POSE
A QUESTION I'M SORRY WHAT IS
YOUR YOU YOUR YOU CALLED ON HER
CELL WHAT WAS IT WHAT YOU WANT
HER HE WAS MY QUESTION I THINK
HE WAS NOT UNDERSTAND BUT-
MISTER GIBSON GO TO GIVE A
TECHNICAL RESPONSE. OKAY SO YOU
WANT TO ASK THE QUESTION AGAIN.
SURE I COULD THIS THIS BILL
SEEMS TO FOCUS ON BUILDING NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- RATHER THAN
SUBSIDIZING SERVICE MAKES THIS
TEAM. BROADBAND PROVIDERS SO I
WAS JUST TRYING TO GET- EQUITY
AND VENTURE PERSPECTIVE IT IS
THE ISSUE AGAIN THAT THERE'S
NOT. ANY SERVICE AROUND THAT
THEN COULD BE SUBSIDIZED OR IS
THERE REALLY THE NEED TO BUILD
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE IN MOST
CASES. FOR PUBLIC HOUSING
THERE'S A FEW ISSUES- ONE OF
THEM WOULD BE THAT SOME OF THE
BUILDINGS ARE ON THE OLDER END
AND SO IT'S REALLY HARD TO-
WIRY BACK THE WIRED UP IT
WASN'T INTENDED TO BE WIRED UP
SO THEY NEED SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE. OFFERS SOME OF
THOSE LITTLE BUILDINGS AND BUT
ALSO THE OTHER THING WOULD BE
TO PROVIDE A BASIC DIGITAL
LITERACY TO THE FOLKS LIVING IN
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY THEY
OFTEN OR NOT OFTEN BUT AT
TIMES. THEY HAVE SOMETIMES A
COMMUNITY SPACE TO PROVIDE THE
DIGITAL LITERACY TRAINING BUT
AT OTHER TIMES THERE IS NO
SPACE AND SOME OF THE FOLKS
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO BEING
ABLE TO GOLD SOMEWHERE. TO TAKE
SOMEBODY'S CLASSES. OUR OUR NOT
REQUIRED JUST DON'T HAVE THE
CLINICAL- YOUR COMMUNITY THAT
MEANS I'M TALKING REALLY BASIC
CLASSES LIKE. LEARNING HOW TO
YOU KNOW USE THE MOUSE AND HOW
TO TURN ON THE COMPUTER. ADULT
CLASSES PROVIDE- YOU PROVIDE
SOME PROGRAMMING BUT USUALLY
ALREADY HAVE TO HAVE THOSE
BASIC SKILLS. IN ORDER TO KEEP
UP IN THE CLASSES. THREE HOURS
IT'S THIS BILL PROVIDES. MONEY
BOTH FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
FREE. SERVICE AS WELL AS MONEY
FOR ADOPTION TRAINING SET RIGHT.
I WOULD AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT WOULD BE INFRASTRUCTURE AND-
ENTRY. I'M NOT SURE THAT WOULD
BE IT WOULD INCLUDE- POTENTIAL
COMPUTERS MAYBE A COMPLETE
COMPUTER CENTER OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT IN YOUR COMMUNITY IN
THEIR BUILDING. IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE WHAT. THERE'S THERE
SENATOR THREE POINTS TO THIS
BILL ONE AS CONNECTIVE ADDING
TO INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN
THREE LITERACY- MS HERNANDEZ
TOUCHED UPON THE DELIVERY OF
THE LITERACY PART SO THIS BILL
WILL IN FACT SPEAK TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE AGAIN
THEY'RE A FACILITY OR-
HOUSINGS- THAT DON'T HAVE THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT SUCH TECH THE CORRECT
NEGATIVITY THAT'S THE REASON
WHY THERE'S THREE MAIN POINTS
THE CONNECTIVITY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE LITERACY-
THAT ABSOLUTELY. THAT'S
EMBEDDED IN FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE. WE'LL GO NOW TO SENATOR
RUBIO. HEY DON'T. TAKE A GUESS
AT ONE MORE FOLLOW UP JUST. SO
THAT'S HELPFUL I PRETEND I
AGREE AND LIKE I SAID BEFORE
THE YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
HOLISTIC APPROACH RIGHT IT WAS
A CLEAR ON THAT ADOPTION
SPENDING SO THAT'S EXCELLENT I
GUESS THE LAST QUESTION IS JUST
HOW DOES THIS ALIGN WITH THE
SPEEDS OF THE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT BOTH HOUSES
ARE WORKING ON IT IS ALIGNED
WITH THE- WITH THE- THE
INTENDED SPEEDS OF THOSE. OF
THOSE LEGISLATION. WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE BUDGETARY
BILL. I'M NOT ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION. YEAH THE- THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS WELL THE WELL WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT BUT IT'S
REALLY BUILT THE LOOK LIKE- WE
KNOW WHAT'S COMING UP ON
THURSDAY AND HIS BILLS BEFORE
US RIGHT NOW AND SO- WE'RE OUR
GOAL IS TO TRY TO GET THIS BILL
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN- THEY'LL BE
WORK. THAT IS NEEDED THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THAT WILL SPEAK TO THE
PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING THE
BIGGEST ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NOT
CONNECTED. AND SO WE HOPE THAT
IT IS CAPTURED- THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL OF FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE IN THE BUDGET FOR THE BILL
WE ARE WAITING FOR THE
LANGUAGE. AND I COULD HAVE BEEN
SOME GENERAL IDEA OF WHAT'S IN
THE BUDGET FOR THE BRACKET TELL
YOU THAT THIS BILL ALIGNS. WITH
WHAT'S IN THE BOOK BUT YOU
TRAILER BILL BECAUSE THIS GETS
TO FINAL. OF THE FINAL SERVICE
END OF IT AND SO THIS THIS
BILL. GENERALLY WOULD CONFORM
AND IF THERE ARE ANY TECHNICAL
MATTERS I'M SURE WE CAN.
READDRESS SOS. I SHOULD ANYONE
IDENTIFY HOW CONFLICT BUT I.
DON'T THERE DOESN'T IT.
MECHANICALLY SPEAKING IN THE
DOZENS BEING SEEN TO BE
CONFLICT BETWEEN THIS BILL AND
THE BUDGET. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR COMING FORWARD I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUES-
FIRST OF ALL AND I THINK- FOR
ALSO- THINKING ABOUT THE
LITERACY PART WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR A LOT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES I KNOW HIS
COMMUNITY WELL AND I'VE WALKED
IT AND I'VE TALKED TO PEOPLE
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
THAT WE DON'T FORGET. EVERY
QUARTER OF CALIFORNIA BUT I
ALSO JUST WANT TO COMPLIMENT
HIM AND AS ALREADY STATED BY
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE YOU
KNOW BEING PART OF THE BROADER
PICTURE TO ACHIEVE PROP AND FOR
ALL ESPECIALLY IN BOTH HOUSES
AND I THINK THAT THIS
COMPLEMENTS OUR EFFORTS VERY
WELL SO WITH THAT I WILL ALSO
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK
YOU. CAPER WELL IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE. OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON SPILL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DODD AND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND JUST
CONFIRMING ONCE AGAIN ONCE MORE
SOME REMEMBER YOU ARE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
IS CORRECT YEP. AND ANNOYING
**** ONCE BUT- JUST TOOK A
CONFIRMED SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED. AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE BY SEVEN MEMBER GIBSON DID
PASS AS AMENDED WESSEL BY
WESSEL HI DOLLY. DOLLY NO.
BECKER HI BECKER HI FORTUS.
BRADFORD RADFORD HI WE DON'T
DOT HI DAD HI AIKMAN. CAKE MAN
HI GONZALEZ. ONCE ALL THIS HI
HELLO. HERTZBERG I HEARD
SPURRED BY MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
MAN HI MAN HI RUBIO HI RUBIO HI
STERN. STERN HI. THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR. AND
WELCOME TO OUR FINAL BILL WHICH
IS OUR. AP THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING OUR VERY
OWN SENATOR HERTZBERG. IS
PRESENTING. SEND US YOUR BIG
HEART FOR WHAT IS ON THEM ON ON
AND ON YEAH WHAT IS ON THE ONE
TINY. THE CARD MOUNTED ON. ITS
CHAIRMAN. NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
CHARLIE WARREN WHO'S A
WONDERFUL FELLOW IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH ALQUIST CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
WHEN JERRY BROWN'S COMING IN
OFFICE WE CREATED THIS REALLY
QUITE EFFECTIVE IN FACT OVER A
THOUSAND LOANS FOR A LOAN
PROGRAM FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
IN THE LIKE THAT ONE SINGLE
DEFAULT BUT ONE SINGLE DEFAULT.
SYSTEM SO SOME REMEMBER KING'S
BILL TAKES THAT LOAN PROGRAM OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IN EXTENSIVE IN
THREE IMPORTANT WAYS FIRST. TO
PROVIDE GRANTS AND LOANS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS TO MAXIMIZE ENERGY
USE INCLUDING. INSULATION
ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS AND
EXPAND THE AVAILABILITY
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THINGS THAT WANT
TO FIND THE TIME THIS PROGRAM
WAS CREATED TO. ALLOWS THEM TO
BUNDLE MULTIPLE PROJECTS AGAIN
AN IMPORTANT FINANCING
MECHANISM AND THREE. INCLUDES
THAT OF AMERICAN TRIBES
ENTITIES ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE UNDER THIS ACT BUT
IT STARTED WITH CHARLIE WARREN
AND ALOE QUESTION SUCH GIVE ME
A MINUTE. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE THAT'S WHAT THE MEASURE
DOES- I PRESENTED ON BEHALF OF.
GERMAN TEEN WHO COULDN'T BE
HERE IT'S DOING SOMETHING ELSE.
PROBABLY EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
OTHERWISE YOU WOULDN'T ASK ME
TO DO THAT. AND WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR ANOTHER VOTE
LET'S SEE IF I HAVE ANY
WITNESSES BECAUSE I NEVER READ
THAT FAR THE DOCUMENTS- SORRY
ABOUT THAT. WE HAVE A HOUSE TO
GET KIM STONE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
STORAGE ASSOCIATION ELOISE
TAURUS FROM TURN. TAKE CERTAIN
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND- POLICE
TAURUS IS NOT AVAILABLE OKAY.
MARK TONY. IS. ALSO NOT
AVAILABLE OR IS IT A LEASE
TAURUS. OUR GOAL IS UP BECAUSE
I HAVE A SCREW THAT I'M NOTES.
THEY WILL BE WITH CAN STARR
FOLLOWED BY LEAST TWO HOURS
AGAIN WILL CONFORM TO OUR
NORMAL POLICY THREE MINUTES FOR
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION SO KIM
STONE. YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND A
HALF. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ONE
OF. THE OTHER HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN INTO THE ETHICS
REPORT OF A FAMILY BILL THIRTY
THREE REPRESENTING OVER SIX
HUNDRED CLEAN ENERGY BUSINESSES
FOR MORE THAN THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA ENERGY YOU'VE HEARD.
I'M THE SENATOR NOTED THAT THE
ENERGY CONSERVATION AT THE BACK
LOAN PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
EASY A WITH THE TOPIC NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. AND I'VE BEEN
ADMINISTERED BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION SINCE THEN AT THE
VERY SUCCESSFUL STATE PROGRAMS
WILL HELP IMPROVE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND GENERATE
ADDITIONAL CLEAN ENERGY. EVERY
SINGLE LOAN HAVE BEEN REPAID
AND THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
RECYCLED BACK INTO THE ECONOMY
TO- BALDING LOAN STRUCTURE
GENERATING THOUSANDS OF GREEN
JOBS. HOWEVER UNTIL NOW BATTERY
STORAGE HAS NOT BEEN ELIGIBLE
TO UTILIZE THESE YOUNG BOND
FUNDS UNDER THIS PROGRAMME.
BILL WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND NOW TRY TO. USE
EASY A MONTHS TO FINANCE THE
INSTALLATION OF BATTERY STORAGE
WITH ALL THE ADDITIONAL COST
SAVINGS THAT CAN BE PUT TO USE
IN THE CLASSROOM AND THE
DELIVERY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND TRIBAL BENEFITS. WE
THEREFORE. SUPPORT THE BILL
AND- DRIED UP. THANK YOU WILL
NOT MORE TO- LEAST- BEGINNING
YOU'RE READY. GIVE A MINUTE NOW.
GOOD EVENING MY IS LI TOR AND
I'M FACTOR. FOR THE FACILITY
NETWORK FOR THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS I'VE BEEN LEADING TURNS
ADVOCACY AT THE CPC CREMONINI
INFRASTRUCTURE. ACTING REPAIRS
FROM EXCESSIVE COSTS. TURNING
TO CROWD SUPPORT AT THIRTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GANG
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
CCPA PROGRAM SERVER THAT
PROVIDES SCHOOLS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES CRITICAL LOW INTEREST
LOANS TO COMPLY WITH ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE MANDATE END OF
SUPPORT TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION. CURRENT
SUPPORTS THE INCLUSION OF
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES AS
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES FOR EIGHTY
THIRTY THREE FINDING AS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO ADDRESS
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC BURDEN THAT STARKLY
FACED BY NATIVE COMMUNITY.
THIRTY RATEPAYERS HAVE INVESTED
OVER ONE POINT FIVE BILLION AND
EASY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
MORE THAN THEIR FAIR SHARE
GIVEN THE SERIOUS AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES FACING RESIDENTIAL
UTILITY CUSTOMERS IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO USE STATE FUNDS
TO FINANCE THE DISPLACEMENT AND
EASY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE BY
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS. OR ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT REPAIRS INTO
SUPPORTING THE ADOPTION BY
VOTING I AM AT THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE
MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF
A. B. THIRTY THREE WILL COME TO
THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE
PRESENT. NUMBER THEN IS IT
NOBODY IS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
EITHER WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. A MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF A B. THIRTY THREE. OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF H. B.
THIRTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND YOUR- THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
MISTER TURNER. THE COMMAND
AGAIN ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND I
SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THE TIME. VERY WELL THANK
YOU WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO
ORGANIZED OPPOSITION TO. AB
THIRTY THREE SO WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY THREE.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
IT EIGHTY THREE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. CAN WE DO HAVE ONE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER.
YEAH. ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE
ONE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. AND WE LOST BY
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS AT THE
TIME OKAY VERY WELL WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND I
JUST WANTED TO ASK SENATOR
CHORUS ON THE MONTH AND YET TO
CLARIFY FROM YOUR COMMENTS THAT
YOU ACCEPT. THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE TEXT I JUST RECEIVED FROM
MY STAFF TO MAKE SURE THEY
DIDN'T MISS THAT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ABSOLUTELY ACCEPT
THE CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS. SET
FORTH ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS TO REPLACE REFERENCE.
OF TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION. WITH ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. FOR THAT
GUIDANCE. AND FOR YOU I'M SORRY
MY OFF THE MIDI FOUR COMMENTS
MOTIONS QUESTIONS. WE HAVE
MOTION. THE MOTION BY SENATOR
MAN IF THERE IS NO FURTHER-
COMMENTS- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MENTOR FOR CEMENT AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A. B.
THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TEAM DID PASS AS AMENDED
WESSEL. BY WESA HI DOLLY. DOLLY
HI BECKER THICKER HI FORGES
PORGES HI BRADFORD BRADFORD HI
DON WHY NOT HI FIGMENT. FIGMENT
HI GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI HELLO.
HERZ BERG BY HERZBERG I REQUIRE.
THE CHOIR BY MEN. MAN HI RUBIO
HI RUBIO I STERN BY STERN HI
THIRTEEN A STIR OKAY VERY WELL-
THAT BILL IS OUT WILL HOLD THE
RULE FOR THE UPS MEMBERS WILL
MOVE ON TO ITEM TO AB SEVENTY
FOUR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE UPS OF MEMBERS. AB
SEVENTY FOUR DO PASS AS AMENDED
PORCHES. GROSS HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI MY CHOIR REQUIRED
BY STERN. STERN HI. TWELVE A
STIR. OKAY WE- HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OF THE PRESS MEMBERS- ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NECESSARY ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN TO PASS
AS AMENDED. FORTUS PORCHES I
GROWTH HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI
MY CHOIR REQUIRE FIVE STERN
STERN I. THIRTEEN A STIR WE'LL
GO TO ITEM FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS. A.
B. EIGHT FORTY THREE BY
SEPTEMBER AGUILAR CURRY DO. OUT
AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI MCGUIRE REQUIRED
BY STERN STERN HI THIRTEEN A
STIR VERY WELL COULD THROW OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON- SECRETARY CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS AT FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE BY SLUMBER GIBSON
TO PASS AS AMENDED. PURCHASE
PORCHES NO GROWTH. K. THAT BILL
IS OUT WE WILL NOW CLOSE TO
ROLL FUN ALL THE BEST AND WE
WILL. ADJOURN OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING. I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING I WANT TO THANK ALL OUR
STUFF FOR THE HARD WORK OF
COURSE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
DILIGENT PARTICIPATION ALSO TO
ALL THOSE IN THE PUBLIC WHO
PARTICIPATED WITH PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES FOR
COMMUNICATIONS. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW
ADJOURNED.